ses propose bonjour et merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur arte france alors
c'était une demande qui émane et des
petits commerçants qui réclamait
justement ce décalage
vous n'êtes pas content justement de
cette date le 20 janvier au lieu du 6
concrètement comment cela peut-il vous
impacté en fait
dont acte évidemment là la décision de
la réflexion que nous attendons ce que
nous avions défendu c'est que compte
tenu du fait que l'année 2020 était déjà
une année très mauvaise avec des baisses
de chiffre d'affaires conséquente depuis
le début de l'année compte tenu du
premier confinement et que le mois de
novembre avait généré 0 chiffre
d'affaires il fallait absolument être en
capacité à l'issue du mois de décembre
de liquider les stocks le plus
rapidement possible pour pouvoir
reconstituer les trésoreries des
entreprises donc c'est en fait cette
logique là et cette crainte
nous avons de devoir après après
décembre
évidemment nous n'aurons pas récupéré le
mois de novembre comme tous les comme
tous les commerçants qu'il soit petit ou
gros et donc d'aller rapidement à les
reconstituer les trésoreries pour
pouvoir poursuivre l'activité en 2021
bruno le maire le ministre de l'économie
avait confirmé un geste envers les
petits commerces qui souhaitait
justement se refaire une trésorerie
qu'en est il des grandes enseignes est
ce que vous avez senti une forme de
discrimination entre guillemets du du
gouvernement non on va pas parler
aujourd'hui on sait que les on sait que
la période est très complexe
y compris pour le gouvernement donc il
ya de toute façon quand il ya un
arbitrage ya toujours des mécontents
le sujet le choix était fait plutôt en
faveur des petits commerçants pas
tellement pour reconstituer leur
trésorerie mais parce qu'il considère
que ça leur permettra d'avoir des marges
plus conséquente en janvier j'espère que
ce sera le cas pour eux que ça permettra
un maximum de petits commerces de
survivre parce que c'est l'enjeu de tout
ça et qu'on nous ait laissé l'enjeu
s'avère que c'est de ne pas mettre en
danger les réseaux et donc ce qui va se
passer probablement c'est que dès dès
janvier il y aura quand même des
promotions et donc par voie de
conséquence on va avoir une perte de
près de deux pertes de promotion très
longue
et mettra plus de temps à reconstituer
les trésoreries les petits commerçants
sera la même chose donc on essaie
espérons que ça ne fragilisera pas plus
que nécessaire des magasins qui sont
déjà fragilisés partout en france alors
on parle du problème du surplus de
stocks est ce que justement une peuvent
devenir un problème insoluble pour les
grandes enseignes
alors il peut devenir un problème
insoluble pour tous les commerçants
qu'il soit petit ou gros je pense que la
problématique elle et elle est liée au
fait que la fin d'année novembre et
décembre est une année extrêmement forte
en chiffre d'affaires que tout le monde
que ce petit comme gros commerçants
avaient déjà les stocks fin octobre et
donc n'ont pas réussi à les vendre en
novembre donc par de manière évidente
ces stocks il faut les payer aux
fournisseurs
si le mois de décembre même si le mois
de décembre est très bon il est
absolument pas possible qu'ils
permettent de rattraper les absences de
vente en novembre donc la fragilité elle
va être évidente après six mois de
décembre est un bon mois de vente
espérons que ce soit le cas là le risque
sera plus faible si jamais on a des
difficultés en décembre ce serait
forcément le cas dès le début de l'année
pour les petits comme pour les gros noms
que écouter on va à croiser les doigts
les magasins sont ouverts avec les
clients sont là pour l'instant et tué et
on verra comment gérer le sujet
aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup et menu l europe 1
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes délégué général
de procos la fédération pour la
promotion du commerce spécialisé